hi dr. Wallach hi how can we help you
yes I have uterine cancer I was
diagnosed last September 4th by a
gynecologist I've been on the 90 for
life oxy body polymers spell shield
osteo oceans gold the radical a phase
selenium and sweeties and been off the
12 bad food and I'm going to start on
the ryl beta 500 this week last week I
started bleeding heavy and so I have
appointment with a doctor at City of
Hope tomorrow morning and on to see okay
oh yes okay how much do you weigh I
weighed 236 okay now and tell are you
five six five six I'd like to see way
like 140 150 and so we need to lose
about somewhere between 80 and 100
pounds right and find to lose that I
haven't been able to lose any weight
okay well I'm going to help you there
and of course it'll be you have not had
a hysterectomy or anything like that
correct correct
okay so yeah let's see here all right
do you have any other issues do you have
any I heard you see sweeties they think
do you have diabetes also no my upline
told me to take the sweeties to make
sure if there's any sugar going on that
it'll I guess take care of it away I had
pre-diabetes about a year and a half ago
but I don't have it anymore okay all
right well it sounds like your program
is very very good you just need to dose
yourself for 200 pounds the only thing
that I would add would be the rev re V
and take two droppers full before each
meal so need two bottles two driver
bottles of the rev per month put a
dropper full under your tongue thirty
minutes for each meal put a second
driver full under your tongue 15 miss
Virgie meal and you'll begin to lose a
half upon two pounds a day that's going
to help take some of the pressure off
your immune system which is your bet
friend I'm glad to see it taken the
oceans gold with the sea cucumber
the extra selenium that kind of stuff
which supports the immune system and so
let's go there and see what the doctor
says
okay and let's see here really everybody
in the households got to clean up the
diet and avoid all the bad stuff all the
inflammatory things the fried foods the
processed meats the all the glutens and
usually when people don't lose weight
okay that means that they're absorbing
calories but they're not absorbing
nutrients and so you really really got
to look you need gluten-free dog food
gluten-free cat food gluten-free fish
and bird food spouse partner
mother-in-law renter roommate kids
everybody you're associated with
especially those that live in the house
have to be gluten free even when they're
not at home because they can't be
washing their clothes the same washer
and dryers you sit on the same couches
sleeping the same beds all that kind of
stuff because they're covered in gluten
does too they're out there in the world
eating gluten okay
and so that cat is imperative if you're
doing such a good job of supplementing
we want you to maximize your benefit
right okay okay so let's do that and
then give us a call after you visit the
doctor and see what they have to say